that's why i like older women older  women are the best they don't get  offended by anything they've seen it all  you know they've been through hell and  back older women are the best like i'm  learning a lot about older women i  learned about menopause that's fun i'm  very ignorant when it comes to this  stuff you know like my aunt's going  through menopause right now she's bummed  out she's depressed i thought that would  be a good time menstruation's over years  of discomfort over come on you graduated  sister it's time to move that tampon  string to the side  why isn't that a party where's that  facebook invite huh hey aunt susie stop  bleeding every month all right  everybody in the pool  all right now you see why i got called a  douchebag